either this guy's back or i'm not going
to see it i'm putting my foot down this
time
bring him back now if you've been paying
any attention to social media for the
last hour or so
you'll see that there's constant things
breaking the internet
or rather the web in regards to
spider-man 3.
within the last hour it has been
announced that alfred molina will be
returning his doctor octopus in the
upcoming film
however we've just gotten another report
that says kirsten dunst will be
returning his mj
andrew garfield will be back as well and
they're close to closing a deal
with toby maguire we're going to be
breaking it all down but if this is your
first time checking out the channel then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
and this is a channel where we break
down all the latest movie news
tv shows games comic books and more i'd
absolutely love it if you subscribe to
the channel
and please drop a thumbs up if you're as
hyped as we are
anyway collider were the ones that first
dropped this report
and they kicked off with the headline
spider-man 3 bringing back alfred
molina's doctor octopus
and past peter parkers just reading that
you know it gets you spider-sense or
tingling
whatever that means and it might also
give you a bonus but we'll not mention
that because we're keeping it pg-13
anyway i've been reading through the
report with my jaw on the floor
and it looks like everyone is coming
back
absolutely everyone the article says
just like jamie foxx's electro
andrew garfield will be back and if sony
marvel can close a deal with toby
mcguire he'll be back too
kirsten dunst will return his mj and i
expect emma stone to reprise her role as
gwen stacy
pregnancy permitting why because this
third spider-man movie starring tom
holland will delve into the multiverse
just like its animated counterparts
spider-man into the spider-verse
i don't think that's a big secret at
this point so why do we have to pretend
it is because we love the pageantry of
it all
now if you've been following the news on
the phone for the last couple of months
then you'll know it's completely obvious
that this is what sony are doing
it was first dropped by annie signor a
couple of months ago
and since then the rumors really
snowballed to the point now
it's just became so obvious on friday
the latin sony channel accidentally
posted a video confirming that past
peter parkers would be returning
and since then it's just kind of got
bigger and bigger and bigger
they've gotten to the point where they
really have to announce this stuff
as they are filming right now and
obviously there's gonna be a lot of eyes
from the public on the project
so someone was gonna spill it eventually
however just getting it confirmed
feels so amazing and if you cast your
mind back to last year you'll remember
that
spider-man there was a danger that he
wasn't even gonna be in the mcu
to get to this point it feels really
really good and i'm
so glad that it's happening however i'm
not completely fanboying out
and i i do sort of have my reservations
now for me spider-man 2 is one of the
best comic book movies ever made
and a lot of that is down to alfred
molina's performance as
doctor octopus often when you watch
fights between good and evil
the the thing that really sticks in your
mind is the villain's performance
and when movies are elevated to a
certain point it's often the bad guys
that pretty much push it there
the way that the character died was an
incredible send-off and i'm not sure
that they're going to be able to bring
him back and fully do him justice you
know
after we said goodbye in that amazing
way and also still give him a send-off
so still a bit trepidatious on this but
it is marvel that they've knocked it out
the park time after time for the last
20 odd movies so yeah i do trust what
they're doing
now what i love about these
announcements is that some of these
characters didn't get to say goodbye
andrew garfield was of course robbed of
his amazing spider-man 3 movie
and toby mcguire was meant to be in a
fourth but that kind of got pushed to
the side
so they're bringing it all together
someone hasn't fixed the door on the
multiverse and i know it was you
but it's allowing these characters to
come back get their time in the
spotlight
and hopefully either continue or or put
a lid on the character
personally i think it's the best way to
do it and after seeing the success of
into the spider-verse
you know it's what we all want to see
now the inclusion of these villains of
course leads to something else and that
is the sinister six
though we don't know the full lineup
just yet the fact that they're bringing
so many villains of old back into the
fold it really makes me think well
there's only one thing that they can be
doing
the end of far from home of course left
peter parker is a wanted man
so it makes the most sense to think you
know there's gonna be a lot of people
after him
they'll be coming from the multiverse to
try and track him down
and you know i think that the the
villains in the other worlds might have
also seen this news broadcast and
realized who spider-man really was
thus they're they're coming to get him
across the entire multiverse
and it's just going to make for a
thrilling ride there's also a
confirmation that doctor strange is
going to be in the film
so it does make sense how they can be
carried across
now the the news is coming thick and
fast
so if i've missed anything here then
i'll definitely update it tomorrow
but obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comment section below
make sure you let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up
and also check out our season 2
predictions for the mandalorian which
will be linked at the end
we go over the best fan theories for the
finale and also
you know break down where we think
things could be going don't forget we're
giving away three copies of the lord of
the rings box
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel
and switch notifications on the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of december
so definitely drop a comment below and
hopefully you'll get picked
if you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents then please click
the join button
as you get to see videos like this early
and also i massively massively
appreciate it
anyway thank you for sitting till the
end of the video i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you